[Music]
you know i i'm um
doing some writing and and one of the
things i was just writing about was
belief
and in that everyday millionaire study
uh we found that 97
of the 10 000 millionaires that we
studied that's all of them okay it's
almost 100
said that they believed that they
largely control their own destiny in
today's america
and we did the same survey with the
general public and only 61 percent said
they believe they largely control their
own destiny oh wow
so
and it's a simple thing it's not a
matter of positive thinking solves
everything because uh i do believe that
if you think positively that's a good
thing versus thinking negatively glass
half better than i mean abundance is
better than scarcity these are kinds of
basic ideas but
but you can't i can't positive think
myself into being
in the nfl i'm 61 and i'm not going to
play in the nfl so no matter how much
positive thoughts i've had so that's
ridiculous yeah but but i but the
concept of believing that i can do
something
and and the old motivator earl
nightingale you said what i can conceive
and believe
meaning i understand it and
and i can see how it's going to work
and therefore i believe it then i can
achieve it i can do it um
and so
if you believe the lies in the political
landscape
that
all rich people inherit their money
which is a lie most don't if you believe
that the little man can't get ahead if
you believe that because you're a race a
certain race you
uh can't overcome those obstacles of
racism racism's real if you believe that
because you're a woman you can't
overcome sexism sexism is real if you
believe that
whatever your thing is your barrier is
is greater than your ability to overcome
it therefore the you do not have the
opportunity to do it you can't do it
then you've established yourself as a
victim
of that
ism
of that barrier
that lack of belief
causes you to do zero towards going to
win right so 100 of the time the lack of
belief causes you to not win well it's
interesting because when i've talked
about this before either in my content
on building confidence or even like my
fear talk at business boutique and that
type of thing is and i use the you know
the classic henry ford quote of if you
think you can or you can't you're right
but what it's what we're really breaking
this down to is
if you don't believe it's possible
whatever it is building wealth getting
ahead in your career starting your
business if you don't believe that it's
possible
then you won't try and then you don't
but it's not because it wasn't possible
it's because you didn't take action
which started in your beliefs and so i i
always you know you and i both have told
the story of the four minute mile the
fascinating part about the four minute
mile is not that john landy or not that
uh robert bannister roger branister
broke it it was that
six weeks later it was broken by john
landy it was broken two more times that
year and it's been broken five hundred
times since high schoolers run four
minutes what had never been done is now
the standard because people saw that it
was possible and so it really does come
down to believing something's possible
even if you haven't seen it because you
will begin to take action in the
direction of making it happen you'll
find a way to make it work you'll find
ways around the obstacles you'll come up
with creative ideas because you believe
it's possible if you don't then why in
the world would you put effort and
energy into being ashamed into something
that's impossible it's insane to do yes
it's insane to put effort energy to
something that and sacrifice for
something that's completely it's going
nowhere it's completely impossible and
so that's what's evil
and dangerous
about these
people peddling
uh the idea that the little man can't
get ahead the idea that it's impossible
to prosper in america today with the
current system so the systems are all
broken why do you think that's so
popular and so prevalent why do why is
that why does it because it gives me an
excuse to lose yeah gives me an excuse
to quit and i didn't really have the
energy
and the courage and the backbone and the
intestinal fortitude to get up off my
assumptions and go do something
and uh and and so if you want to be a
couch potato
now you've got a now you've got a
narrative you've got an excuse you got a
narrative that makes it okay because
well i'm such and such and people like
me you know they don't win
and the problem with your theory when
you've got that narrative is there's
people like you that have one yeah yeah
that have already proven your narrative
wrong yeah it becomes a self-fulfilling
prophecy it does if you if you that
that's my point
is
it's not the power of positive thinking
it is the power of belief because belief
says
i don't know exactly how i can get there
but i can see that if i save 15 of my
income
if in good growth stock mutual funds how
that's going to turn into a million
dollars that's a mathematical thing i
can see how that's going to happen and
so i'm going to do that
i can see how if i pay extra on my house
when i'm 32 i'm going to have a paid for
house in amarillo texas
as an electrician substation and my
wife's a pharmacist you know i mean i
can see how i'm going to be able to do
that
and and when you can conceive it see it
then you start taking the action then
when all the naysayers start coming at
you you're like
you guys can't do math yeah i mean
what's wrong with you people yeah you
can't do math because you you don't have
some kind of false belief it's not uh
some kind of puffed up
dreamland skittles and rainbows thing
right it's it's a based on a reality
right and it's like you know the first
time i ever ran five miles
without stopping
i knew
i could do 13.
yeah and when i did nine
i knew i could do a full marathon yeah
once i did a couple of 13 halves i
really knew i could do a full yes and
there's something powerful in that
when you do something hard you do
something new you do something you've
never done before where the result is
you surprise yourself and at the end of
that five miles your natural thought is
what else can i do that i'm not aware of
and you start dreaming bigger dreams and
going for bigger goals and you go i can
do a half marathon i can do a full
method there's something so powerful and
pushing yourself outside your comfort
zone where the result is you surprised
yourself i didn't know i could do that
what else can i do that i'm not aware of
that that experience you just described
is so powerful and moving people into
into doing things they never thought
they could do becoming a millionaire
running a marathon atomic habits and
some of these other pieces of research
that are out there um and deloney could
probably chime in on this big time
there's something about our spirits our
psychology our emotions our spiritual
walk um even our intellect that once it
is stretched to a certain point it
cannot return to the same shape that's
good because you know the second million
they always say it's easier to make
second million than the first why
i know i can do it i've already done it
that's right i mean you know first i
mean i i'd be highly disappointed if i
went out to run a half marathon now if i
didn't complete it right
i mean and i'm not in training for one
right now i'm not gonna go do it but i
mean i i've run i don't know 20 25 of
those things and and if i set out and
did the training exercise if i didn't
i've never not completed one right and
it wouldn't it just doesn't occur to me
but the first time right
i thought i was gonna die
and i and i knew i was crazy about the
ninth mile yeah you know there's a whole
bunch of crazy people around me doing
the same thing running this race you
know but but then when i finished i'm
like
it wasn't long before your brain starts
going
i think i'm thinking i'm gonna do this
again okay i'm gonna do this again
because you've had the success the brain
craves traction and you you know you
never reach the point that you go i
can't do it again right because you know
because you've done it that's what
that's what builds confidence people
think that confidence is this feeling
it's a certain gene people are born with
them like no it's really comes down to
courage where you act courageous you do
it scared you push yourself outside the
comfort zone you do that first half
marathon once you survive it because you
will
well then you have proof and go oh i can
do that so i know i can do it again your
second one you're confident approaching
that second one because you have proof
you've done it before but it started
with just trying just putting yourself
out there and being courageous and after
a while you're like now when i first
walked on my first stage as a public
speaker i was scared out of my mind now
i'm confident it's through the
experience of doing it it doesn't occur
to you that you won't be able to do a
good message yeah
yeah and so belief does matter yeah
so you can be a baby steps millionaire
uh you can start from wherever you
whatever your dysfunctional screwed up
background whatever obstacles you've got
i know they're there i know they're real
i'm not saying they're not real i'm
saying you can do it anyway so get after
it